[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein leckeres schnelles Rezept.
Ich werde Bananenkuchen backen,
Bananenbrot.
So nennen es die meisten.
Ich bin heute hier in unserer kleinen, privaten, schicken Küche.
Denn unsere Küche drüben ist belegt.
Murat dreht da gerade ein Video
mit Sturmi.
Na ja,
mal gucken, ob ich die Küche wieder heile zurückbekomme.
Ansonsten gewöhnen wir uns einfach an diese Küche hier
und ich drehe ab sofort hier.
So können wir es auch machen.
Ja, Bananenkuchen,
da gibt es Tausende Rezepte.
Viele machen das ganz klassisch.
Viele machen es vegan.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, wir machen heute
einmal die ganz klassische Version,
so die Sally-Version,
und einmal dann noch eine vegane Version,
wo ich euch einfach zeige,
welche Zutaten ihr austauschen könnt,
um das Bananenbrot eben auch vegan zuzubereiten.
Viele nennen es zwar Bananenbrot,
aber für mich ist es einfach ein Kuchen.
Weil es ist halt kein Brot.
Aber egal.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz die Zutaten.
Ich nehme dafür
180 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Backpulver,
eine Prise Salz
und einen viertel Teelöffel Zimt,
70 Gramm Kokosblütenzucker,
50 Gramm Mandeln,
– die habe ich bereits fein gemahlen –
zwei Eier,
Vanilleextrakt,
reife Bananen.
Und hier habe ich noch 75 Gramm Butter.
Ich muss schon sagen,
die Bananen sind jetzt nicht so reif.
Die sind schon besser.
Also die dürfen ruhig so aussehen.
Die nehme ich dann auch.
Und da nehme ich drei
und das sollten ungefähr 300 Gramm sein,
also geschältes Gewicht.
Ich wiege die gleich ab.
Was mache ich jetzt zuallererst?
Ich werde die Butter schmelzen.
Das mache ich jetzt hier.
Also Butter schmelzen.
Dann kann ich schon mal die Bananen schälen und wiegen.
Ich wiege die Banane jetzt einfach
direkt in so einen Mixer rein.
Wenn ihr so braune Stellen habt, ist es gar nicht schlimm.
Die kommen einfach mit rein.
308 Gramm sind perfekt.
Liegt noch in der Toleranzzone.
Dann gebe ich hier Vanille dazu.
Und ihr könnt die Bananen entweder zerdrücken
oder einfach kurz durchmixen.
Ich mixe sie jetzt kurz durch.
Ich gebe einfach noch die Eier dazu.
Dann habe ich schon mal so
die flüssige Komponente.
Also kurz pürieren.
[Musik]
Dann kommen die Zutaten hier rein.
Ich habe jetzt hier Kokosblütenzucker zum Süßen.
Kokosblütenzucker schmeckt nämlich schon von sich aus
total karamellig und malzig.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch weißen Zucker
oder braunen Zucker nehmen.
Aber geschmacklich passt er schon perfekt dazu.
Ist schon sehr lecker.
Dann gebe ich den Zucker dazu
und verrühre die Zutaten schon mal ein bisschen cremig.
[Musik]
Wisst ihr was? Bevor ich jetzt hier die Version fertig mache,
fange ich parallel schon mal mit der veganen Version an.
Denn da ersetze ich die Eier durch Leinsamen.
Also pro Ei könnt ihr 10 Gramm Leinsamen nehmen.
Also brauche ich jetzt 20 Gramm Leinsamen,
werde die zerkleinern, also schroten,
mit 70 Gramm Wasser.
Denn das muss mal quellen.
Und dann kann ich nämlich beides gleich gleichzeitig backen.
Das ist vielleicht ganz gut.
Dann brauche ich nur einen Backofen.
Also noch vegane Version.
Da
– ich habe es auch ausgewaschen extra,
damit es nicht mit Eiern in Verbindung kommt.
Jetzt nehme ich leider doch die Bananen,
die noch nicht so ganz reif sind.
Aber ist okay.
Ah, sieh an. Das sind jetzt kleinere Bananen.
Da brauche ich vier Stück.
300.
Und da nehme ich jetzt die Leinsamen.
Die werde ich jetzt gleich hier drin selber schroten.
Das ist auch ganz wichtig,
denn ihr braucht diese Bindeeigenschaft und diese Proteine
und das Fett aus den Leinsamen.
Wie gesagt, das Wasser dazu.
Und jetzt püriere ich es
und lasse es dann etwa 15 Minuten quellen,
damit die Leinsamen einfach mit dem Wasser
– oder sich im Wasser eben ausbreiten können.
Okay.
[Musik]
Und hier jetzt, wie gesagt,
Vanilleextrakt noch dazu.
Ist nämlich auch vegan.
Und dann kann ich die Leinsamen erst einmal quellen lassen
und mache mit dem klassischen Rezept weiter.
Also hier einfach noch ein paar Minuten verrühren,
bis sich der Zucker schön auflöst.
[Musik]
Also beim veganen habe ich, wie gesagt,
die Eier durch Leinsamen ausgetauscht
und dann tausche ich noch die Butter
einfach durch Sonnenblumenöl aus.
Und das war es im Prinzip schon.
Also mehr ist es gar nicht.
Jetzt habe ich hier die Eier-Zucker-Masse verrührt,
hier die Leinsamen mit den Bananen einfach stehen lassen.
Da kommt jetzt auch Kokosblütenzucker dazu.
Und jetzt mache ich erst mal ganz kurz den fertig
und dann den, okay?
Also das heißt, hier zur flüssigen Masse
einfach die trockenen Zutaten geben.
Das sind Mehl, Backpulver,
Zimt, Salz und Mandeln.
Kurz einrühren.
Warte. Die Butter nehme ich auch gleich mit rein.
Die sollte jetzt nicht heiß, sondern einfach nur flüssig sein.
Da könnte man jetzt auch Öl nehmen,
aber so für den Geschmack
ist Butter schon immer ein bisschen besser.
[Musik]
So. Teig eins ist fertig.
Jetzt hier auch die trockenen Zutaten,
die Mandeln
und das Öl rein
und auch kurz verrühren.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier zwei Kastenbackformen aus Glas.
Die sprühe ich jetzt mit Backtrennspray ein.
Ist halt auch echt eine schöne Menge,
also die man einfach mal machen kann,
wenn man echt Bananen zu viel hat
und die etwas verwerten muss.
Und
dann hat man die einfach schön verbacken.
So. Einmal der vegane Teig.
Der ist ein bisschen kompakter.
Wenn er euch zu fest ist, könnt ihr ihn gerne
mit Pflanzenmilch einfach auch strecken.
[Musik]
Der ist ein bisschen flüssiger.
Das macht jetzt aber auch nichts, denn
da ist ja Ei mit drin und Ei bindet ganz gut.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr möchtet, nehmt ihr jetzt noch mal eine Banane
und schneidet sie längs auf und legt sie noch obendrauf.
Dadurch wird das Brot oder der Kuchen
so ein bisschen weniger haltbar,
also es wird schneller schlecht.
Aber, ich meine, man hebt das ja auch keine fünf Tage auf.
Also so gebacken
wäre es dann schon so fünf, sechs Tage haltbar.
Aber ich finde, so ein Kuchen ist auch schnell gegessen.
Von daher kann man auch schön
die Bananen noch dazu geben.
Ist halt geschmacklich und optisch richtig cool.
Und Bananenkuchen ist sowieso eher so kompakter
und dafür aber richtig saftig.
So.
Megacool!
Schnell gemacht,
tolle Bananenresteverwertung.
Und jetzt kommen sie direkt in den Backofen.
[Musik]
Der Bananenkuchen ist fertig!
Und ich habe einen Gast.
Das ist meine Cousine, die Jale.
>> JALE: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Ja. Und Jale darf jetzt probieren.
Der Kuchen löst sich übrigens
auch supereinfach aus den Formen heraus.
Ich habe das einfach rausgestürzt,
auf so einem Kuchengitter abkühlen lassen.
Aber ich glaube, leicht warm ist er noch.
Also einmal Standard, einmal vegan.
Ich würde sagen, wir probieren einfach.
>> JALE: Ich bin gespannt.
>> SALLY: Bist du eher so Mittelteil oder eher Randstück?
>> JALE: Mh, kannst mir ruhig Randstück geben.
>> SALLY: Ja? Sollen wir das probieren?
>> JALE: Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Einmal hier.
Guckt mal. Sieht auch gut aus.
Und so Bananenbrot kenne ich von Sarah.
Sie sagt nämlich,
das muss so ein bisschen matschig sein innen.
Stimmt es, Sarah?
>> SARAH: Yes.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
Okay, probier.
Ich probiere auch.
>> JALE: Ich probiere auch mal erst den hier.
>> SALLY: Aber schon so schön locker
und trotzdem sieht er saftig aus.
>> JALE: Riecht lecker.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und ich glaube, am nächsten Tag schmeckt er noch besser,
weil er dann so durchzieht
und sich das Aroma so entfaltet.
Hm.
>> JALE: Schmeckt gut.
>> SALLY: Und nicht so süß, gell?
>> JALE: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JALE: Echt lecker.
>> JALE: Und der ist jetzt vegan?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JALE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Der ist sogar weniger süß.
>> JALE: Wie der da.
>> SALLY: Hm. Ich kann dir auch sagen warum.
Hier waren die Bananen reifer
und die waren noch nicht so reif.
Und je reifer, umso süßer.
Aber ich finde es gut, weil
ich es eh nicht so süß mag.
>> JALE: Also ich finde jetzt beide lecker.
>> SALLY: Wenn man unreife Bananen hat,
kann man die einfach in den Backofen legen für 15 Minuten.
Dann werden die auch schneller reif.
Habe ich vorhin nicht gemacht.
Ja.
Und Sarah ist das gerne mit Erdnussbutter.
>> JALE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JALE: Bestimmt auch lecker.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Oh, ich finde es voll gut!
Aber ich finde, wenn man mal zum Beispiel
keine Eier zu Hause hat
und man hat aber voll die reifen Bananen
und will die Bananen irgendwie verwerten,
dann ist das eine coole Alternative
>> JALE: Ja.
>> SALLY: und vor allem eine coole vegane Alternative.
Ansonsten würde ich, glaube ich, auch eher den machen.
>> JALE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber so...
>> JALE: Aber super Alternative.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JALE: Also mir haben sie jetzt beide sehr gut geschmeckt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und ich glaube, wenn man das jemandem gibt,
dem man nicht sagt, das ist vegan,
schmeckt man es auch nicht raus.
>> JALE: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Also es schmeckt schon gut beides.
Ja.
Also das war das Bananenbrot.
Und mit Erdnussbutter
probiere ich gleich die nächste Scheibe.
Danke, Sarah!
>> JALE: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Also das Rezept gibt es in meiner App,
in der Sallys Welt App,
und natürlich auch auf dem Blog, auf sallys-blog.de.
Und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Mal.
Tschau!
>> JALE: Tschüss! Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Danke fürs Probieren.
Schon gut.
[Musik]